précisez pour lebron et sa marque est un
ami voilà non c'est vrai marter
connaissez pas mais quand il s'appelle
vincent vous connaissez oui bon on se
connaît a mais pas celle calme-toi vous
attendez on sait que nouveau sport aux
sports à la face à moi ta grande gueule
quoi il a croisé au restaurant dit ça
donne quoi vous êtes reconnu e sport oui
on est on est amis on était amis c'est
tout ça dans la même salle what the
artist qui se connaissent et gravité
tant lors les mêmes passions le sport
pas voilà vous avez sympathisé c'est
vous qui êtes allés vers le oui oui oui
je salue ouais mais ça je suis quelqu'un
de civiliser mais quoi cette envie de me
dire que vous êtes arrivé à la
sainte-baume effet marc lavoine vous
êtes matthieu delormeau quoi voulez dit
je n'avais pas la première fois que n'a
pas été simple et quoi les i j'aime
beaucoup ce que vous faites vous l'avez
compris de vecchi